the Year 2005 the problem greenhouse
gases are destroying the planet the
solution a system devised by the UN
intergovernmental panel on climate
change which rewards companies disposing
polluting gases with carbon credits the
more harmful the gas being disposed the
more credits were rewarded sounds like a
great idea with the best of intentions
what could possibly go wrong
hydrofluorocarbon 23 a manufacturing
byproduct of the common coolant
hydrochlorofluorocarbon 22 was seen as
particularly harmful allowing a large
number of credits when destroyed so
manufacturers predominantly in India and
China ramped up production of the
coolant creating more of the dangerous
by-product which they immediately
destroyed A system that netted the
manufacturers tens of millions of
dollars a year when the U.N announced
the plan to stop the scheme Chinese
producers threatened to vent their huge
stockpile of gas directly into the
atmosphere but some activists labeled
environmental extortion